When we put together all five of the criteria
in SMART, we end up with compelling and direct
objectives. But that’s not the whole story. Now
that you’re equipped with a concrete definition
of SMART, here are a few best practices
to consider when setting your own goals.
1. Create goals that reflect your unique needs
SMART goals are only as good as the KPIs you set.
Not all business needs are the
same, even within the same industry.
Choosing KPIs that don’t
reflect your business goals,
just because someone else is using them
or a post on the internet tells you to,
can send you in the wrong direction. While we do
talk at length about certain metrics to avoid, you
should always carefully consider what makes the
most sense for your personal or business needs.
2. Use SMART as a form of
communication and transparency
Like any form of communication, having clear
information helps teams and managers act upon
it better. SMART is meant to help provide
a way to communicate exactly where you are
and how well you’re doing. When everyone
in the business understands the goals and
criteria to reach them, they
can work together to succeed.
3. Carefully plan the best
route, and check in along the way
It’s a great idea to plan the order of operations
and the order of achievements that will help you
best reach long-term goals. Because SMART
emphasizes specific and bite-sized goals,
you’re likely to have a series of goals;
some goals will be in flight simultaneously
and some will be dependant on the success
of other goals. Use historical data to help
anticipate issues along the way and plan
for check-in milestones to adjust KPIs.
If you have a goal that is time-bound to a
year, you might plan to check in each quarter.
Much like using a GPS, check-ins can help
tell you if you’re veering off-track.
4. Remember that SMART isn’t just
for large company or team goals
SMART is a set of criteria most often
cited as an incredibly useful way to
set and track business objectives and metrics,
but they also work well on the personal level.
Feel empowered to use the SMART criteria for, or
as, an individual or small team. When employees
can track how well they’re performing with
great goals and metrics, they can better see
how their performance will directly impact the
organization’s performance on the larger scale.
Or, if you’d like, consider using SMART
outside of a business context entirely.
There’s nothing stopping you from applying
this knowledge to a New Year’s Resolution,
fitness goal, job search, home
improvement project, or anything else.
5. Understand that SMART only works
if the long-term strategy is good
It is important to also acknowledge
that SMART has two distinct flaws.
First, SMART breaks down a
larger strategy into small,
digestible, and achievable parts. If the
overall strategy or vision is rotten,
then SMART will only help you achieve
the goals that poor strategy dictates.
Second, SMART is a method of setting goals,
not a way to analyze successes and failures.
When setting goals, be sure to build in time
to make your goal setting process SMARTER by
including the self-explanatory Evaluate and Review
stages. Always keep an eye on ways to design your
next SMART goals better than your last goals. When
you evaluate: think about what pitfalls popped up,
about questions you should have asked,
people who should have been involved,
and so on. At the end of the day, SMART is just
a set of criteria and set of considerations;
it’s up to us to reflect on our methods
in order to set better and better goals.
In summary, A SMART goal is used to help guide
goal setting.SMART is an acronym that stands
for Specific, Measurable, Achievable, Realistic,
and Timely. Therefore, a SMART goal incorporates
all of these criteria to help focus your efforts
and increase the chances of achieving that goal.